an attorney for the grandfather of a
toddler who fell to her death on a Royal
Caribbean cruise ship tells CBS News
that prosecutors are offering a plea
deal salmonella
was surrounded by reporters as he left a
puerto rico courtroom yesterday he's
charged with negligent homicide in the
July death of his granddaughter 18 month
old Chloe Wiegand our lead national
correspondent David Begg know has been
following this David good morning such a
tough story we understand more
surveillance video has surfaced the
surveillance video was actually released
to a Puerto Rican TV show which aired it
last night we don't have the video but
the family attorney allowed us to watch
the video because we wanted to see it
for ourselves to be able to report
exactly what it showed and we've
consistently reported the grandfather
walked up to the railing which was 18
inches from the window he looked out
over the railing that he reached down
picked up Chloe held her above the
railing and then passed the railing and
she fell now the grandfather maintains
he didn't know the window was open
prosecutors believe he was reckless and
we just got this statement last night
from the family about the release of the
video saying were shocked by the
disgraceful misconduct that led to the
release of this footage and our sole
motivation for not releasing the video
was to make sure our older son didn't
have to see it CBS News has learned that
prosecutors have discussed a plea deal
with Salmonella attorney in Puerto Rico
who is representing the Indiana
grandfather in the criminal proceedings
there is nothing in writing yet
according to the attorney but he tells
CBS News that the agreement would
require an ello to plead guilty to
negligent homicide in the death of his
granddaughter Chloe weakened in exchange
he would serve no jail time and get the
minimum probation and supervision that's
the puerto rican defense attorney jose
perez he says anello does not want to
plead guilty and would rather clear his
name at a trial but he says anello is
considering the deal we interviewed mr.
anello in November just standing there
and I just remember screaming that I
thought there was glass some of the
people have been on the boat have
written to me and said David the windows
are tinted and so it is pretty easy to
recognize that it's open I am color
blind so that's been told me that's
something that you are color blind
bye-bye indeed I've been told that that
might be some reason but I'm not the
expert on men Chloe's parents blame
Royal Caribbean and last week they filed
a lawsuit against the cruise line
alleging that it failed to provide
reasonably safe children entertainment
areas including reasonably safe windows
what are you wanting in we want them to
fix their cruise ships so that no other
kids get hurt Royal Caribbean has said
its hearts go out to the family but they
have no comment on the criminal or civil
proceedings the grandfather is due back
in court in Puerto Rico next month and
Anthony as of this morning the
grandfather though considering that plea
deal wants to go to trial in order to
clear his name
yeah thanks David what a difficult spot
he's in I know I see why he would want
to consider the plea deal but I also
wouldn't want to put my family through
this either it's a total tough place
that he's in still others say look I
want to clear my name if you're not
guilty of a crime I can't see pleading
guilty under any civil action can if you
want to end it for the family yes but I
can't imagine if it was a jury trial
that a jury would convict him you plead
guilty I think you may live to regret
that it's difficult anyway all right
thanks again David